a baby formula manufacturer has
announced a recall of several popular
products after the fda says several
babies got sick and one reportedly died
one local family says their child was
affected and now they want to warn
others madison kimbrough joins us live
in north las vegas tonight and madison
how is that family doing tonight
you know while they're still very
emotional i think there's a sense of
relief in knowing the type of idea of
what's been making their child
he's had sick different choking episodes
to where we've had to use a plastic
suction stick down his throat his nose
just to unclog him jamir coffee sharing
what his three-month-old baby samir has
been going through as the infant has not
been able to keep down his formula samir
has also been experiencing fevers and
several bacterial infections on friday
the fda announced a massive recall of
baby formula after receiving reports of
illness and one death the fda warning
people not to use the powdered formulas
similac alimentum and elicare all
manufactured by abbott nutrition those
of which were all consumed by baby samir
especially with us being new parents
people didn't really take us serious
they made it seem like oh you know it's
the first time so you're going to panic
about everything but i'm pretty sure you
know when something's not right with
your child samir's grandmother says the
moment they got the news of the recall
they had an idea of what was making
their three-month-old so sick knowing
this it's like aha you know especially
since we now know that every single
milk that he was on was included in this
recall as for what's next the coffee say
they will continue taking samir to
doctor's appointments and see if he
progresses this upcoming week while
being off of these formulas and finding
a food he can keep down so he can
continue to grow
it's important to note that all the
abbot formulas being recalled were
manufactured at the same plant in
michigan and have expiration dates after
march 31st reporting live in north las
vegas madison kimbrough live local now